yeah like um you gotta wake up man
Carmichael's been commuting in on his
electric minibike and he's been looking
pretty cool doing it I mean the bike is
awesome but that helmet
everyone's been taking note the guys
don't know this yet but it's a little
Christmas come in July over here at
court or dismal the guys who made that
helmet over a true rock decided hey we
like your videos we want you to protect
your noggins when you're riding around
on all those you know what these are
yeah eight helmets did you guys know we
were getting these these really nice
like magnetic snap locks begin the math
let's see that chrome face things are
getting crazy with a little bit of
experimentation we realized creating
blow darts out of PVC pipe we're way
more accurate we can control the
velocity that arts better and most
importantly there we go watch this you
see that doorway over there should we
play a game Nick I think we should play
a game dude we've never played a zombie
game where you do exclusively headshots
yeah we'll have a bunch of survivors one
of them turns into a zombie in Russia in
the year 1984 there were
a nuclear facility that melted down
leaving nothing but the workers stranded
inside what they don't tell you about
your Nobel is that what they don't tell
you about this is that there were
zombies the thing is they're all wearing
these government-issue Super Soldier
helmets and the only way to kill a
zombie with a helmet on is by by
sticking one of these darts to the
helmet so that the thermic can activate
and pour down through the helmet
piercing the brain of the zombie in any
zombie infection game if you're touched
by a zombie you become a zombie
and as the Horde grows your chances of
survival grow thinner but before we
begin someone needs to be the secret
zombie you're shooting the zombies but I
don't know hit the zombie but you don't
know who the zombie is you up might even
be the zombie I could be four three two
one let the games begin
might be a tactical sniper position
actually I've lost a lot of good friends
so my trust barrier just down I'm gonna
go hide the zombie apocalypse started so
I missed my bus
we're gonna look I'm I'm on overwatch
here you can spawn zombie 30 seconds
sharpshooter the best there is the
longer we work together the longer we'll
survive okay we need a safe house
my gun just jams up so I got my my
thermite dirt
[Music]
seems fine
teams go for now
hey zombies over here
hi just hard hard for hide
dude the headshots are still I'm
surprised actually how many we were able
to get that shotgun is pretty sick huh
okay so the one thing that that works
well with is that the darts don't
consistently stick yeah I mean they
definitely stick
they stick most of the time but it adds
that little bit of like failure strategy
is being near no one trusts Noah to get
be a zombie
well I forgot my thermal camera but my
bipod should provide pretty steady shot
nizam be Zuko just just being cautious
here I'm just gonna stay back here I
have a little time here I'm gonna email
my meemaw and let her know this might be
the last time we ever speak I'll never
get a Wi-Fi connection through these
concrete thermite walls will I do well
thankfully there's an ear I'll be here
right here
thanks arrow for sponsoring today's
video hero is a Wi-Fi system that can be
perfectly tailored to any home so if you
have thick concrete walls or you have
trouble getting a decent signal from a
single router consider Eero their system
creates a blanketed Network all over
your home through the use of these
wonderful beacons that are attached to a
base right over there so I don't even
need to go over there in addition they
offer advanced security by checking the
sites you visit against the database of
millions of known threats they also
offer content blocking so you can choose
what the kids or the zombies see or
don't see at home and of course they
also offer ad blocking so you can get
rid of all the annoying pop-ups on all
your devices back to me ma right here
dear me Mom this might be the last time
Siddiq remember you can get $100 off an
aero base unit two beacons and a year of
arrow plus by going to erode comm slash
corridor crew and using the promo code
corridor crew at checkout I love you I'm
God my friend needs me why you doing
this man
don't do it he went he went out why did
he kill himself it is murder he gave up
he was bold
we're the area they're stuck in there
with
[Music]
[Applause]
crap they cleaned out all the darks
there's no dark
welcome to the zombie location a zombie
nation your benefits will be explained
to you in two to three years Oh
excellent
yeah for now Justin eat some brains
enjoy
[Music]
[Applause]
hey Jared was sticking me like I thought
it was the finish to the helmet was
making it hard which might be the case
I'm not sure mind at the least because
they were just nothing was more
terrifying than having to thermite my
own friend in the chest before he became
a zombie that was great that was a lot
of fun I'm gonna take a quick shower
if you gonna contain some babies these
helmets are awesome these are really
cool they should have a little for the
hydration pouch on them those straw